[Music]
john
we don't spend much time on this show
talking about politics
uh oh um because
i'm a firm believer that you control
more of your life
than they do correct and yet we are you
and i are
you're have a doctorate in counseling
and you and i were discussing that
we are seeing a new syndrome in the
mental health field uh
pop up the post deranged disorder
and it manifests itself in one of two
ways depending on who you voted for or
you deeply believed in
if you voted for and deeply believed in
donald trump you are
irrationally depressed and think that
the world is coming to an end several of
my friends are
contemplating you know where they're
going to live
other than the united states i mean they
just have lost their dadgum minds
and then if you uh voted for biden and
were deeply invested in that emotionally
you have the
post-election deranged disorder and are
irrationally exuberant
we won we won as if you're gonna get a
car that's right
like like oprah got elected you get a
car and you get a car
and you get a car no loans for anybody
yeah yeah we're just gonna we're gonna
just completely it's it's communism now
and we're all gonna be entitled now
guess what they're both
wrong this is a mental disorder yes
there's a third one
and those are the folks just uh
collecting coffee and bullets
as because they think that the currency
is gonna be that's gonna be the new
currency right
we're just gonna trade coffee and
bullets for food we're gonna eat our
pets
which if that's the case tennessee's in
pretty good shape we're gonna be in
great shape tennessee and texas and
arkansas that's gonna be the no the no
go zone right yeah yeah
well for certain yeah oh my gosh yeah
yeah and really all joking aside but not
really joking
some of you and some of you that would
fall within the circle
of my personal influence as well as the
influence from this show
need to get a life you are not dependent
upon washington d.c
if you are a liberal and you think that
washington dc is going to solve
america's problems you are stupid if you
are a conservative and you think that
washington dc is going to solve
america's problems you are
stupid and if you think it's going to
fix your life
you're stupid i'm 60 years old i've been
working for 40 plus years
earning money paying income tax and none
of these people have sent me money
there's been quasi-socialists and people
that were conservative just to the right
of genghis khan in the white house
during these times
and none of them fixed my life or run my
life
just kept it plugging along huh well i
mean yours too yeah
you know your mama and daddy my mama and
daddy i mean it's
guys what happens at your house is more
important than what
what happens at the white house
why is that so hard for people to wrap
their head around we look
we want the lone ranger to come and
rescue us
want to we want this to get easy someday
that's what it is this grown-up thing is
going to get easy someday and somebody
else is going to do the work for us
and someone else is going to do the
sacrifice for us and we can be little
children again
we all want that that life has this
hidden
lottery thinking i'm going to get
discovered it's not going to happen the
colonel parker's going to come along and
i'm going to be elvis
that this whole radio and publishing
thing and
this whole uh being in the media thing
is gonna get easy all of a sudden right
that i'm not gonna have to deal
with crooked people right
that i'm not gonna have to deal with
people who betray you and talk about you
behind your back who said they were your
friends
i keep thinking this is going to get
easy welcome to grown-up land boys and
girls
it gets harder harder and harder there's
a great theologian
um named rich mullins who said the worst
part about being a christian is that
it's every single day
and you could never memorize all the
books of abraham to where
you never had to do anything else right
and i've you can't finish
right and i've rattled that around in my
head that works for exercising i can
never have such a good workout on a
on a monday that you don't have to be
done for the rest of the month right
donuts yeah i'm just gonna i don't have
to i did this good workout on monday so
i need a box of donuts every morning the
rest of the week
and i'll think about it doing another
one in december right yeah and it's the
same with your money it's the same with
your marriage
you wake up every day and decide
i'm gonna love her no matter what yep in
spite of myself
and i'm gonna default to these things
that i know i'm gonna let these children
live another day
well i don't know man i got a four and a
half year old she is pushing on me dave
oh man um you know you you
part of being a grown-up is nobody's
gonna do it for you
and it's every day it's every day it's
every day make your bed
wave to your neighbor every day make
your bed
yeah do your stuff man be kind every day
and guess what
you know you being a troll on twitter is
not going to make your life better
no one has ever been convinced to vote
politically or to become
or to meet jesus by someone being mean
to them never
it's never happened no one has ever
yelled and cussed and screamed at me and
convinced me to do anything
that's right ever ever right in my whole
stinking bald-headed life it has
never happened no you know and so stop
it stop
stop it be a grown-up what happens at
your house
which is what we teach you around here
we help you with you right
and you're the solution to your problem
and you're the problem
to your problem just like i am at my
house and you are at your house john
so the post-arranged post-election
deranged
disorder is real uh
and it has to do if you place your hope
on the wrong things which will always
cause your hope to dissipate
because guess what if you place your
hope on that preacher he's going to let
you down
100 people he's a man that's right he's
going to screw up something
go say something you don't like someday
you place your hope on that boss these
people come to work here
they got stars in their eyes they think
dave ramsey's the second coming it takes
him about 20 seconds to figure out
that's not right
it didn't take me that long but i got
what you're saying i get what you're
saying
right thank you what you're saying three
two
okay that's right but yeah
in in it's this at some point folks have
to go look in the mirror
and say i've got to be responsible yes
there is
hard stuff yes there's a ton of things
we got to do together but you can't
control
anything it starts with me looking in
the mirror and saying i'm going to
choose
it's irrational exuberance and it's
irrational depression it really is
irrational
right because it means you place your
hope on something that is not logical
that is not going to work it's not going
to work
it never has so give people one or two
things
tell me a time that washington dc fixed
your life and i'll shut up about it
you know i can't think of one i mean it
doesn't freaking exist
and yet people are running around
hooting and hollering and honking their
horns like biden's gonna send them a car
and my conservative friends are just
like they really do
they some of them really are buying
coffee and bullets i mean oh my gosh
and gold bars another stupid crap in
this morning when i got to work here
someone had put a note in my box
that made my whole day start off right
what did you say he just said thanks for
being you and thanks for some stuff i
had done
but i'm telling you oh it was not
looking for somebody else to solve the
problem somebody wrote me a note it's
that easy
to be about changing your community and
your neighborhood in your home be nice
be kind there's a good start
don't place your hope on the wrong
things